the nfl continues to rocket toward the
draft it's just 22 days away the jets
made the big move this week trading sam
darnold to the panthers
and now they much like the 49ers last
week and i really do appreciate the
teams are spacing these out it would be
too much to deal with all at once but
just like the 49ers last week when kyle
shanahan knew you don't have to be coy
anymore everybody knows you're taking a
quarterback at number three everybody
knows that's what the jets are doing at
number two here is joe douglas the
general manager of the jets yesterday on
the topic of whether they have locked in
to taking quarterback at number two now
that they've just traded their starter
away
i think that's a fair assessment to say
rich i think based on on the decision we
made yesterday um you can kind of see
the the direction we're heading what did
you think of steve young's comments on
the radio apparently he did some
detective work and spoke to some members
of the coaching staff and he said the
jets are quote committed to zach wilson
uh steve's uh steve's plugged in to uh
byu pretty well um i know
uh it it was good being out there at the
pro day and uh just had an opportunity
to you know speak to his representatives
um say hello to a couple members of his
family quickly
and you know byu put on a great pro day
for for the entire nfl first class
uh first class organization and
it was a good day out there you know um
[Music]
like i said we're we're excited about
this class and we're excited about this
quarterback class
yeah they're taking zach wilson and and
isn't it funny to see
the demeanor how relaxed right he's
changed he's smiling that's first thing
that i noticed
don't have to watch every single word
that is formulated by your mouth yeah
just just it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter worst case scenario is the
jaguars take zach wilson which they
aren't going to do and we get trevor
lawrence oh well oh well hope that
doesn't happen yeah right yeah no no
it's uh i i do i agree with you i think
that's the first thing that jumped out
to me the pressures off of the situation
in general in a lot of ways one they
figured out how to deal sam darnold and
got you know good compensation back for
that you know two they can now look to
the future and go wait okay we know who
we got coming in here this is cool we
could start thinking about our offense a
little bit how we want to play with this
guy all that type of stuff
and you know i think the um
i lost my train of thought here but oh
the and then and then of course i think
the third thing is well i forgot it i
forgot what i was going to say i had one
more point
but either way you can't be you you're
flummoxed by the picks that the jets
have totally
messed my mojo up there i looked at the
graphic and i started going into it but
either way you see the moves they made
here and
i mean joe douglas is sitting in a power
position for the next two years for a
team that's real crappy in a bad spot
you know now he's he's got his
quarterback and here's the thing i was
gonna say he's also happy the third
thing i was going to say is because
people and public perception has gotten
behind zach wilson
that it's changed you know i think
everybody
now hey listen everybody knew what
trevor lawrence was i think two months
ago zach wilson was still a question
mark for people you know the casual fan
who's not in the the weeds like you and
i or other people who are really just
all over nfl football every day but i
think that you know through this process
what they've seen is you see highlights
and hey a lot of a lot of fans and
people go off what they see on
highlights and i can here in new york i
can speak too specifically why they
didn't get behind daniel jones one of
the reasons was this is i have a lot of
friends they used to go i don't get it i
see the highlights and they're not even
that great a highlight so how could he
be the number six pick in the draft you
know there's something to that and i
think people have watched the jets and
zack wilson and they've seen all these
you know highlight shows and everything
like that and i think even to the novice
you have to look at it a little and go
damn i don't know it just looks cool and
looks good and then when you have the
pro day off of it that also looked wow
right i think now it's just like man joe
douglas is feeling himself he's going
all right got rid of the quarterback
we're going into the future i got a guy
i've had my eye on for a long time here
because we've heard rumors about joe
douglas liking zach wilson from about
the halfway point of the year and now
zach wilson helped him out to confirm
that like hey i am the man i'm worth the
number two pick and that's why i think
we got a happy joe douglas
yeah and i think part of the reality for
jets fans and most football fans college
was such a strange season this year
and yeah it was you never quite knew who
was playing when or it all kind of got
thrown together and it was the big
schools that got the most attention and
i just don't like byu's anybody that's
gonna get a ton of of a following or or
a focus well that's what i think that
played into it too yeah and and now
people are waking up to it of course he
is a boomer bus prospect zach wilson
that was big news over the weekend
boomer bus prospect yeah they all are
boomer bus props exactly every first
round pick is a boomer bus prospect but
the jets who
rolled the dice on a boomer bus prospect
three years ago with sam darnold they're
right back there again they're trying to
get their franchise quarterback and this
is the way you do it and it's obvious
they're going to have a quarterback and
as joe douglas said keeping sam darnold
wouldn't have been the best situation
for anyone especially not for the jets
because now now under the cba if you
pick up the option it's not just
guaranteed for injury it's fully
guaranteed they'd have been in for 24
million or so for uh sam darnold over
the next two years while they're paying
zach wilson what the second overall pick
in the draft gets no and it's just that
would be a horrible situation i mean
just horrible
nobody wants to deal with that all the
focus of the jets after the draft would
just be on the quarterbacks and you know
who's going to get the first reps and is
it going to be a fair competition and
it's like what we talked about with the
49ers if you know they're going to draft
the quarterback at three and of course i
think it's mac jones if they have him
and jimmy garoppolo in the locker room
that doesn't make sense to me that does
not and that would be the same here this
is that's how you divide a locker room
and that's how you can ruin a football
team so i think it's smart that they did
it now you know they acted fast probably
why they realized like hey
you know there's there's some teams out
there and there's not that many spots to
be filled let's try to make something
happen and obviously carolina had a
liking for sam darnold so you know great
move by that especially if you believe
like i believe that zack wilson can be
an aaron rodgers patrick mahomes type
talent and that would always bring a
smile to your face if you think that and
you're an evaluator
the the difference too between the jets
and the 49ers is this the
deadline for the money becoming
guaranteed for sam darnold is may 3.
yeah for jimmy garoppolo the deadline is
basically week one of the regular season
there's no triggering that's true right
his contract it forces any any sooner
action so the 49ers have the luxury of
waiting to see if an opportunity arises
and all it takes is one fluke injury and
an opportunity arises to trade jimmy
garoppolo and get real value for him if
you're willing to carry the 25 million
cap charge and if you're willing to deal
with the potential that we've discussed
on multiple occasions for
locker room
turmoil as some players line up behind
garoppolo and others line up behind mack
jones or whoever they take with the
third overall pick but the jets
because of that may third deadline they
needed to do something sooner than later
and they recognized their best deal was
to just go ahead and get it done now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports